hey i'm cam and you are watching reality
check that's right 64 of people can't
tell the difference between ps4 xbox one
and pc at least that's according to a
study done by me and some of you in fact
here's the skinny over 2 700 people took
part in an online test which task
participants to watch three different
gameplay clips back to back and then
attempt to identify which was ps4 which
was xbox one and which was pc the
results were then collected over the
course of a few weeks
okay so a few disclaimers was the test
perfect no was it scientific kind of
should it be taken as gospel probably
not but does it make an interesting
point about how we value graphics
definitely
but before we dive into the details of
the test reveal the correct answer and
talk about what went well and what i
would maybe do differently next time
let's take a moment to recap and rewind
on monday the 16th of february i ran an
experiment in our gamespot studios in
london i got seven volunteers to play
three different games on three identical
setups their task to tell me which they
thought was ps4 pc and xbox one all
other ways of identifying each machine
were controlled for all they had to base
their decision on was how the game
looked the graphics to get the full load
out of the test and how people got on
watch that episode of reality check the
problem though was that the test pool
size of seven people was way too small
to draw any meaningful conclusions so i
devised a more simple one that would
allow anyone anywhere to take part so
how did i do it well i added three video
clips at the end of that previous
episode all consisting of far cry 4
gameplay one clip was captured on ps4
one on xbox one and one on our gaming pc
i asked those watching to vote on which
they thought was which in an online poll
simple stuff now obviously web
compression was always going to be a big
problem as a standard for the show i
uploaded the video to gamespot and
youtube at 1080p resolution and 60
frames per second and both were
compressed using the h.264 codec now
this is fine for general viewing but
there is always a degree of quality loss
and artifacting so it was far from ideal
for this test so in an attempt to combat
this i also uploaded all three clips at
1080p 60 packaged up as one movie
uncompressed to google drive for anyone
to download and watch for themselves
okay time to reveal the correct answer
clip number one was ps4 number two was
pc and the final clip was xbox one this
was the single most popular answer with
982 votes or 36 percent the other 64 of
voters though did get it wrong either
getting one or zero correct
interestingly though if you shift the
focus of the test to see how people
performed at picking out the pc from the
other two consoles then the results
actually get a lot better with 58 of
people correctly identifying the
non-console that was made up of the 36
percent who got it correct plus 22
percent of people who just got the
consoles the wrong way around as for the
rest of the results here they are 391
people or 14 voting ps4 xbox one pc 311
or 11 percent chose pc xbox one ps4 291
or 11 again thought it went xbox one ps4
pc and finally 104 or five percent of
voters chose pc ps4 and then another pc
the eagle eye amongst you will notice
that that last one was wrong the final
option should have been xbox one not a
second pc so how did that happen well
that's what we call a derp otherwise
known as human error it was very late
and i was very sleepy when i made that
poll simple as that whoops but it
doesn't really matter though because it
was an incorrect answer either way
so that was the experiment and the
results but like i said it wasn't
perfect so it's time to look at some of
the comments you guys had but also think
about how i might do this differently if
i was going to do the test again
one big issue a lot of people commented
on was my choice of clips in the
experiment now i used three clips from
the same early stage in far cry 4. the
areas though weren't identical but this
was a deliberate choice
you see i wasn't attempting to emulate
the artificial setup of a graphics
comparison rather i was trying to create
real world gaming conditions if that
makes sense
sure identical clips would have likely
made it slightly easier as you could
have compared identical textures like
for like but the way i see it is that
texture quality dynamic lighting and all
other graphical settings are all
consistent in a whole game area
and more to the point if graphical
differences between platforms really
weren't the fuss that a lot of people
tend to make over them then we should be
able to tell under the conditions i set
that was my logic anyway but i'm willing
to be talked around on that one if i
were to repeat this test so let me know
what you think the main issue for me
though with these results is that i have
no way of knowing how many of those who
voted did so after watching the online
version and how many actually downloaded
the clips downloaded votes are far more
powerful as you can eliminate all that
nasty compression and give people a much
fairer test next time i'd find a way so
only after actually downloading the file
could you cast a vote
then there's the case of the gaming pc
the specs of the one i used are on
screen now and i think it's fair to say
that it makes for a reasonably powerful
gaming pc probably to the higher end of
average that most pc gamers have
plus far cry 4 was running at the preset
ultra settings i'll admit though that it
would have perhaps been fairer to have
the most powerful pc i could get my
hands on so next time i'd jamming a
titan x in there alongside a better cpu
but despite these changes i would make
in the glory of hindsight i still think
these results are really interesting for
me this test simply underlines how
graphics are not the most important
factor to consider if you're trying to
decide which setup is best for you
ultimately ps4 xbox one and a gaming pc
are fairly close in visual quality sure
you can line up labeled textures and
spot the highest resolution one in a
graphics comparison but when it actually
comes down to sitting on your arse and
having a great time gaming your ability
to tell and therefore the importance of
those extra pixels or quality of
lighting or whatever start to diminish
other things like online services the
ability to host servers digital
distribution platforms controllers what
your friends use
these are far more important when
deciding which is best for you
it's all about our own individual
preference but that's just what i think
do you guys agree or do you disagree or
do you have any ideas about how i may be
could it on the test differently let me
know in the comments down below or by
hitting me up on twitter at camfrassrob
thanks for watching
so it's time to think about some of the
comments you guys had but also what i
might do differently
that was squeaky comments you had but
also think about how i might do this
differently
right now's my chair
but also consider what i might do
differently if i was going to do this
test again
how did that happen if you guys agree or
disagree or if you have any other ideas
about how